Hey, I'm Dale! This is Making with ML.
Today, you'll build
a Machine Learning model
right here, right now,
and in under ten minutes.
I'll show how to use a tool
called Teachable Machines
to train a model
from your browser really fast.
Let's get to it!
Today, I thought it'd be fun
to train a model
that recognizes letters
that I make with my body,
like A, B, C.
But for starters,
I'll just train the model
to recognize the letters Y, M, C, A.
I'll use Teachable Machines to do this.
It's one of the coolest ML tools out there
because it allows you to train a model
that's for photos, audio, or a pose,
without writing any code
and it runs straight in your browser.
All you need to get started
is a computer with a webcam.
So first, go to
teachablemachine.withgoogle.com
and click Get Started.
From here, you'll see there are
three different models
you can train in each audio and pose,
but we'll make a "Pose" project.
The idea with Machine Learning
is to train a computer
to find patterns in data.
So step 1 is to collect training data.
In the UI, you can collect training data
right from your webcam,
so I'll create a bunch of examples of me
making the letter Y with my body.
First, create a new Class
with whatever you want to detect--
in this case, the letter Y.
So, as you can see,
the UI's already detecting
my pose and my facial expressions
using a pre-trained model,
but what I really want it to do
is recognize the letters I'm making.
Let's take some example pictures.
Take pictures of yourself
from lots of different angles
and distances from the camera,
which will prevent the model
from overfitting on features
about the room or the camera angles.
Now I'll collect some data
for M, C, and A.
Once you've done collecting data,
click Train Model.
When you hit this button,
TensorFlow.js actually trains
a new neural network from data
right in your browser,
so do not close this window.
Your computer is doing
a lot of work under the hood.
Click Advanced and Under the Hood
to learn more how it works.
Once your model's done training,
you can try it out
right here in the browser.
Tu-tu, tu-tu, tu-tu tu!
Hmm, hm-hm.
It works!
The best thing about Teachable Machines
is it's really easy to export your model.
You can either download it
as a TensorFlow model file,
or you can have
Teachable Machines host it for you,
and it'll even give you
this nice shareable link.
Plus, there's a nice
JavaScript code sample
that you can use to easily add
the model to your web app.
To learn about my favorite
easy-to-use Machinery and tools,
check out my blog below.
That's it for now.
If you liked what you saw today,
tell me what you want me
to build in the comments.
Until then, see you next time.
♪ [music] ♪